for me when I'm playing a multiplayer
game with real people my strategy's
going to change pretty subtly at the
beginning of the game but as soon as
that you make contact i think is when it
really starts to to flip particularly
when you're sitting right next to the
guy like they're sort of under the table
diplomacy going on and you know all this
kind of stuff or trash talking as the
case may be but the character the game
changes a lot I really like to play
civilization with people like in the
same physical space because you get that
that awesome feedback I think it's
always a more irrational game like you
play like like schoolchildren in
multiplayer you I don't think you can
help it like just just knowing that
there's like there's actual human
competition and like one-upmanship and
petty rivalries going on will make you
to make dumb moves in the game and make
you like overextend yourself and and you
know do something just for spite or just
for amusement and that's that's like
part of the fun like single-player civ
is very can be very rational it's very
strategic especially the higher
difficulty levels there's very little
room for error that especially if you
know how well the hell well the AI can
play and exactly how it works and it's
fun to just let go of that in a
multiplayer game and just you know like
for instance I know will I knew he was
going to come the soldiers I knew who's
going to come with covert ops so I just
had those ready and I was like I'm those
defenses are prepared and I probably
wouldn't have emphasized those quite as
quickly if I was playing against AI well
there's so much competition in a
civilization game in any civilization
everywhere and in beyond Earth we've
added all these new new vectors for that
kind of competition and multiplayer is
really cool because that plays out like
it did for us you know between human
players not just the AI so while I think
mechanically the multiplayer in beyond
Earth is very similar is civ5 with the
exception of pit boss the addition of
pit boss and some bug fixes and things
like that these new vectors for
competition and for drama make it a
really lively experience and a lot of
the asymmetry that we've added into the
game also makes it a quite different
kind of multiplayer experience the cow
the asymmetry income
in that game is is really like starts
like within the players own solar
civilization it's just getting your army
on the field and making and tuning it
customizing and making it the army
that's yours and then when you like can
use it to roll over your your opponents
civ it's all the more satisfying because
it's a unique army like it has a unique
attack and defense profile and it's like
a reflection of your attitude and your
style and your skill a lot more so than
in civis traditionally been able to do
what what makes a good combat player and
civ isn't always necessarily being sort
of better than the other players but
being especially good at your own style
and we really emphasize that and beyond
earth like the way that the different
affinities grow up to be totally
different army styles like the way that
they fight is totally different if you
are better at being your army than that
guy is at being his and you're going to
do better and so it's a it's a sort of a
fun puzzle to solve a like how to master
your own army style and then how to use
it to outfox the other guy so we've
we've done a lot of talking and
preparation and actual design to make it
so that there isn't only ever one way to
play an infinity like affinities are
meant to map to any play style take in
our multiplayer game I was playing
supremacy but I was going for a hard
pacifist cultural supremacy which is a
very like strange version of it compared
to the sort of aggressive battle robot
style that most people think of so when
you go to war with anyone all players
who are at war act in sequins after all
players who are not at war so it's like
peaceful world gets to play concurrently
and then warlike people get to play in
the order that they are in which is
their score yeah it's based on score
order so if you are on the bat I thought
you're on the back foot you get the
advantage of getting to go first and
we've we've retuned how that score is
calculated and won't go into the details
because it's probably one of the more
complex calculations that happens in the
game that number that ranks you is a lot
that goes in there but we've tuned that
and made a lot of changes to how that
calculation works be more appropriate
for this game and to be more fair
because it doesn't matter now when you
have to take those turns in sequence I
think measuring your progress against
other players is kind of difficult in a
sieve game if you can't
see them so you can't see how big their
territory is you can't necessarily see
how many cities they have or how many
units they have until the very very late
game so it's important to see who's
ahead so that was civilization beyond
Earth multiplayer thanks for watching
the game comes out october twenty fourth
we can't wait for you to play it